[Music]
this is the Poinsettia also known as La
Flor de noche buena the Christmas star
the lobster flower the flame leaf
euphorbia polcarima and one of its
oldest names
in the U.S during the holidays this
plant usually potted with bright red and
green leaves can be seen everywhere
but the history of how it got here is
less obvious
and it's all wrapped up in the
controversial Legacy of this man Joel
Poinsett
[Music]
poinsettias are native to this region
from Mexico down into Central and South
America
the Aztec called itla show sheep meaning
flower that Withers and unlike the
Potted varieties we see today in the
wild these plants look like tall shrubs
that flower in the winter season it was
a prized plant the brilliant red colored
leaves which are leaves and not actually
petals were used to dye textiles while
the sap of the plants was used
medicinally
and by the 17th century likely because
of those red leaves that bloomed in time
for the holiday season Spanish Friars
used the flowers to decorate elaborate
Nativity displays in Mexico
Spanish-speaking Mexicans named it La
Flor de noche buena the flower of
Christmas Eve
and for many in the country it became
forever linked to Christmas time
for hundreds of years common knowledge
of the plant was largely contained to
where it grew natively that is until
Joel Poinsett
in 1825 Poinsett a diplomat amateur
botanist and South Carolina native was
appointed as the first ever U.S minister
to Mexico
as The Story Goes he came across Guetta
Shoshi in a town called toxco took some
cuttings and shipped them off to the U.S
to distribute to his botanist peers
eventually they caught on in the U.S too
they were debuted at an 1829 flower show
in Philadelphia
nurseries began to grow and distribute
the plants in the U.S and its popularity
as the Christmas plant exploded
the name poinsettia stuff as a way to
celebrate Joel poinsett's Legacy one
that would grow to include not just
minister to Mexico but U.S Secretary of
War and founding member of the
institution that would later become the
Smithsonian
but his legacy is a tainted one
take poinsett's time as minister to
Mexico where he aggressively attempted
to increase American influence in the
country one letter to Secretary of State
Martin Van Buren focused on the
potential to Enlighten Minds with
liberal ideas revealed his thoughts on
the Mexican population
stating the spaniard's constant
intercourse with the Aborigines
who were and still are degraded to the
very lowest class of human beings
contributed to render the Mexicans a
more ignorant and debauched people
Poinsett a slave owner himself back in
the U.S believed racial hierarchy
between the indigenous and white crail
population could help progress in Mexico
Poinsett also sought to expand American
borders at the time the US looked like
this and he was tasked with negotiating
a deal to buy Texas from Mexico but
before he could negotiate that deal he
ended up meddling so much in Mexican
politics that he was asked to leave the
country it happened like this by helping
to establish a network of Freemason
groups known as the largest
International secret society he helped
to gather men in Mexico with
pro-american politics eventually that
organizing laid the groundwork for a
public pro-america political party in
Mexico to gain steam angering many
within the Mexican Government
his interference with local politics
created so much conflict that Mexicans
even coined the term
poinsettismo to describe officious and
intrusive conduct
and in 1829 at the request of the
Mexican president Poinsett was removed
from his post
a few years later after returning to the
U.S he was appointed U.S Secretary of
War
in that role he oversaw the forcible
displacement of an estimated 20 000
indigenous Cherokee People from their
homes to push them West as a part of the
Indian Removal Act
it was part of the ethnic cleansing
known as the Trail of Tears that would
go on to displace roughly one hundred
thousand indigenous people that cemented
poinsett's place in history
a man who believed in American expansion
at all costs
back in his home state of South Carolina
poinsett's name lives on in many ways a
state park a highway a hotel even a
statue
though his most well-known namesake is
likely still the plant
poinsettia production grew even more
after years of engineering creating
Fuller and more compact plants
today it's an industry worth around 170
million dollars in the US alone
and importantly it's a market the U.S
has cornered while shutting Mexico out
due to decades-old sanitation laws there
are restrictions on Mexican poinsettia
Growers who want to export potted plants
to the U.S
it means the vast majority of the plants
we see in stores in the U.S are grown
here
in recent years many have found a
different small way to honor this
plant's history
by rejecting the name poinsettia and
using its Aztec name
a name that hopefully reminds people of
the true origins of the plant of the
Season
thanks for watching this Christmas
edition of missing chapter our series
that explores how our past connects with
our present this year we've covered
everything from reparations in New
Zealand to Native American Sign Language
you can find a link to all the episodes
we've made in the description below for
each episode we spend weeks reporting
speaking with experts and pouring over
archival images and documents to present
fact-checked stories you can help
support our journalism and keep it free
by making a gift to box at box.com
support Vox Dash video with your support
we're able to keep telling these stories
about hidden histories
thank you